ce tracteur en panne sous un hangar
c'est un peu le symbole de la situation
des petits planteurs de cannes achetées
d'occasion et qui coûte maintenant trop
cher à réparer les planteurs ont alerté
toute la saison
les comptes de leur coopérative la cuma
sont en rouge avec 120000 euros de
déficit on n'a pas de fonds de roulement
on n'a pas d'argent ne pourra pas payer
les salariés donc il ya répondu tout
comme jose 10 à la fin de ce mois ci là
je ne pouvais pas payer les salariés et
je ne vois pas comment on va faire avec
si les pouvoirs ne s'en mêle pas et je
ne vois pas comment on va sortir il faut
compter 72 ne vaut pas pour l'année pour
les salariés donc cette année on a le
plus vu que 3500 tonnes de cannes
donc si vous faites tourner ses 100 x 18
ans ça ne fait pas beaucoup on a plus de
salaire à payer que des rentrées de la
cuma c'est la coopérative historique des
petits planteurs qui regroupe une
cinquantaine d'entre eux la sécheresse
de cette année a frappé fort pour toute
la profession la récolte n'a donné que
160 mille tonnes au lieu des 300 milles
habituel les frais ont aussi augmenté
car le désherbant pollueurs n'est plus
acceptée mais les professionnels ne se
sentent pas écoutés
les chefs d'entreprise ont des
impératifs et voudrait qu on nous prenne
davantage au sérieux pourquoi je parle
de sérieux il y a des années nous avons
dit si on supprime les désherbants il
faut trouver avant des systèmes
alternatifs des outils des machines on
nous écoute est comme ça discrètement et
aujourd'hui nous sommes en train de
couler parce qu'il n'y a pas eu de
solution à nous proposer
faute de comptes à jour la cuma ne peut
monter de dossier auprès de la ctm les
planteurs ont trouvé la solution de
lancer une cagnotte sur internet
un comble pour une profession dont la
matière première fournit chaque année
des médailles d'or au concours de rome